this pro-life bill in texas is
anti-woman
it's it's a bunch of men
saying that women
can't kill their children
and so it's anti-woman
except for the
men who can get pregnant
and
uh because they can and uh then the
women who
are who are men
um
uh hmm
aoc can you explain please
none of this is about supporting life
what this is about is controlling
women's bodies and controlling people
who are not cisgender men this is about
making sure that someone like me as a
woman or any menstruating person in this
country cannot make decisions over their
own body and people like governor abbott
and mitch mcconnell want to have more
control over over a woman's body than
that woman or that person has over
themselves
hold on wait is it a woman's body or a
menstruating person's body or it's a
woman or a person and it's the men who
first of all in the spirit of
reconciliation and compromise i'm
willing to make a deal right now with
aoc
any
menstruating person who wants to get an
abortion i'm fine with that that's fine
if you are a person right now who is
menstruating and you want to get an
abortion
that's fine that's fine by me
that's
fine you know generally speaking people
who are menstruating are not
uh pregnant i don't you know aoc i
thought she would know the fundamentals
of biology here at least the real but
apparently not that even
but i can i'm happy to enlighten people
when you're pregnant you stop
menstruating that's how it goes so
that's fine there we go we there's my
carve out okay menstruating people can
have abortions also menstruating person
seems a little sexist to me doesn't it
men
waiting per sons how about
women
actually better than women's trading how
about
[Music]
whoa persons how about
son how about
how about whopper daughters trading
per daughters
about that aoc
i see your woke language and i raise you
a
whopper daughter straight in for
daughters
take that
i want you to enter into my bed okay
come into my bedroom
because i sleep like a baby you
you might not sleep like a bit you might
be having trouble falling asleep and
staying asleep well one of the best
things you can possibly do to start
getting enough sleep is to start getting
enough magnesium unfortunately most
magnesium supplements use only the two
cheapest synthetic forms since they're
not full spectrum they will not fix your
magnesium deficiency or help you sleep
better which is why i recommend
magnesium breakthrough buy buy
optimizers simply take two capsules
before you go to bed you will be amazed
at how much better you sleep and how
much more rested you feel when you wake
up it is really really important to get
enough sleep at night for an exclusive
offer right now just for my listeners go
to magbreakthrough.com
knowles and use code knowles10 to save
10 when you try magnesium breakthrough
and one more thing
for a limited time buy optimizers is
also giving away free bottles of their
best-selling products p30m and mazzyms
with select purchases so go to
magbreakthrough.com right now get your
exclusive 10 discount plus a chance to
get more than 50 worth of supplements
for free
what's funny about it of course is that
you have these two ideas that are in
conflict with one another the idea that
uh
men and women are not different at all
that men can become women women can
become men there's no difference a woman
needs a man like a fish needs a bicycle
and the idea that women are this special
class of victims and they're oppressed
by men and you've got the oppressor and
the oppressed and you can't change that
and it's just an eternal fact of society
and people notice that these things are
in conflict
you see the same type of conflict in the
debate between homosexuality and
transgenderism homosexuality says that
men are men and women are women and some
some boys like other boys and some girls
like other girls and you're born this
way and there's nothing you can change
about it and transgenderism says
actually there's not even any such thing
as boys and girls boys can be girls and
girls can be boys and men can be women
and so if you were to apply the logic of
transgenderism
to
homosexuality then you would lose the
idea that you're born this way and you
can't change it because not only can you
change your sexual desires but you can
change your sex itself so the solution
then to homosexuality and the question
that used to be asked which is who would
choose this who would choose to be born
this way would be oh well just change it
you're a boy who likes other boys well
now just you know be a boy that likes
girls or or be a girl that likes boys
but just you can just change it because
it's all fluid right
or if you were to apply the logic of
homosexuality to transgenderism you
would lose the entire concept of
transgenderism people are pointing this
out as maybe this will be the moment
that the left comes undone by its own
logic it won't it won't
because
it actually it all kind of goes back to
second wave feminism when second wave
feminism says a woman needs a man like a
fish needs a bicycle there's no
difference between men and women the
only difference is some some people have
long hair or something
some people wear skirts
what they're saying is that
man
equals woman they are exactly the same
indiscernible
so if man equals woman that leads
naturally to the homosexual rights
movement and even to gay marriage
because if there's no difference between
men and women then of course men should
marry men and women should marry women
the word marriage would be redefined
just by that very premise and if there's
no difference between men and women then
of course a man can become a woman and a
woman can become a man
because those categories don't mean
anything so unfortunately it actually
does sort of make sense the reason that
that when you listen to aoc she's
getting a little tongue-tied
and she she sounds she sounds a little
bit like the taliban doesn't she
and the person and the woman
the reason she's doing that is because
her argument doesn't have logic to it
it's just grunts it's just it's just
interest it's just desire
it's not it's not anything logical
but that's that's our
that's our politics these days
[Music]
[Music]
you